well the thomas and mack transformation
really a great sign as the national
finals rodeo takes center stage in las
vegas tonight so many people excited to
sit ringside this year and the event's
post kobit 19 return is also a great
boost for our local economy sasha loftis
was out with all the cowboys and the
cowgirls tonight she joins us live with
more sasha
denise and brian you could really feel
all the energy out here today at the
thomas and mack now this event is huge
for those who love it but it's also
great for our local economy as we
continue to bounce back from last year's
pandemic related punch
it's that time again when boots broncs
and 10 gallon hats take over we're so
excited to be here this is my first
rodeo it may be her first rodeo but it's
certainly not southern nevada's here we
go as the national finals rodeo makes
its triumphant return to the thomas and
mack real glad to have it back here in
las vegas those we spoke with say
they're itching to get back in the
saddle after the kovid 19 pandemic
forced the event to go dark last year
how about cheyenne wimberley but it's
also a big boost for a rebounding
economy as over 100 thousand people
descend on our city really it's a
critical component to the local economy
expert brian gordon says events like nfr
have always been important but now
they're crucial as we work to bring
things back to pre-pandemic levels there
are a lot more special events happening
and that's helping to fill in the holes
where we're still lagging on things like
convention travel or international
travelers so if you have plans to head
out and soak in what many call the super
bowl of rodeo be with everybody and
everybody's spirits are so happy no this
excitement is roping in an even brighter
future here locally
[Music]
now you still have a while to check out
the nfr here it continues through next
saturday december 11th cowboy christmas
is also back a lot of people enjoy that
that is over at the las vegas convention
center reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now